o desafio é incrível como direto
eu estou sempre disponível para atender
responder a desafios dessa envergadura
você tem que fazer a investigação é
empresa minha casa sempre o caraças
sempre o craque recebeu graças à efe que
casa pia diz ao pai que compravam
bilhões
sendo assim não é propriamente uma
surpresa para mim porque as gravatas e
ovinos que fossem ao estádio acontece
caminha primária a relação afetiva
ligados com uma garrafa do vinho
aconteceu em janeiro e 10 novatos que já
não tenha certeza que já teve na casa de
terceiros para que vai cuidar aqui quais
praia
minha mãe queria que eu me fazia
adivinhar a apresentar resultados com as
festas e max dá um salto que continua a
dar por isso meu brilho na categoria 77
que era fácil se você está longe de
lembrar o efeito é prender pinho que era
vibrar passado pela forte para graças
mais graves limpas e paulo josé serra se
ele espera ver um filme ou uma garrafa
que já o rio de janeiro para gravar
direta saber o que é feito na bacia que
tinham sobras sejam os próprios vídeos e
fotografias
tenho duas coisas como aconteceu contra
o seu antigo rocha seria demasiado
e qual é o objetivo do projeto é o
primeiro vídeo braços da mãe como eu já
fui um bom time e está o jec muita gente
que é o tipo de relacionamento
responsável
eu posso entender o mesmo brilho que
fazer o trabalho mas não quero de volta
disso
a pista é nildna aumentar em 100 cartas
lá mas cada vez que a gente sair porque
qualquer coisa que era chamado quando ia
fazer meu já comeu upgrade ok
as obras no qual é feita a verdade do be
dois gols e deu já prevê o projeto tinha
no sangue uma na área da equipe mais
forte do que eu nesse campo em saber se
estava a desenvolver certo na quadra nos
dois numeral mede pelo número ganha
consciência e com a consciência também
resultado que teve lugar na época o
nível pior ainda não tenha sido dada
nós fechamos pelos céus feito
regulamentado o que é que um passo pra
mim era em casa em casa de forma
bastante responsável de todos os
envolvidos naquela altura era fila
querem dizer que vou para o natal só
exemplo é mais um programa que vai casar
o estúdio também está com problemas
médio e as coisas devem acontecer vai
acontecer depois discutir uma segunda
experiência e vão ver em contexto que w
que se tome bisca de ir para portugal
concretamente
para coimbra e não se manifestar o seu
lado brinquem a 50 pela internet
christian a taxa de julho a taxa de
julho das táticas mais directo a tudo de
melhor para viver o personagem com isso
de certo filme tweet misterioso por meio
das aulas e claro a chapa de qualquer
coisa e fez bonito na altura da esquina
da situação o prefeito final sobre a
distância estáticas base para festas e
bebidas alcoólicas e as escolas não
estavam literalmente 50 metros
então eu diria mas valeu a pena capital
na china com capuz que a capoeira de
julho de ser convocado - você vê outros
creche e uma vez uma cerveja é muito
consciente do fato mas uma vez mudou a
minha vida inteira baliza de março terá
mesmo marisa esse pouco do véu integral
bairro no final das aulas que estava a
tentar não só para apanhar um adversário
na dívida
foi a segunda vitória consecutiva e água
pé das coisas muito desagradáveis foi o
pique de moeda comum e nem consegui ir a
pé para o outro lado da cidade no
passado o passar do ponto de vista mesmo
acessar a via é certa eu salvio e gaitán
e com tvs dois ou três dias depois de
receber a esquadra promessa foi estava a
acontecer
ela voltou a acontecer e voltou a
acontecer ou exatamente um ano depois no
adversário exatamente a mesma era a
mesma da mesma forma
a partir daí produzirá qualquer um
estaria o ibra o qual quer estudar em
coimbra ou vinagre o rompimento das
barreiras e das queimas das fitas e data
o que falar de cerveja chocolate ficha
pra você passa toda vez que vejo como
qualquer cidade de coimbra
frança sei se está incluída está com
ibra 10 km 70 lento vai ser tudo igual a
via teve essa é a idéia da obra nós
temos mostrado é que mil palavras
postado esquecem dessas bebidas teve
diversas atletas em fim da greve
ai eu estava equilibrada antes de ir
para a universidade de münster costurar
no ibope pela web aí tua essas coisas
mais estudados na entrada que diz tudo
como está o trabalho de qualquer coisa
manter uma taxa ainda mais do que
escrevi como sócio era assessor para
cada filho sócio dessa técnica cuida do
bairro vai ficar um pouco nos anos 30
que era de ficar pop de hoje para jogar
bola de futebol da equipe chamada gracie
orçamento com os meus tios que está em
pequim está tranqüilo para obra de
pressa e o animal bagaça também é mais
gata de se contratualizar mais ou menos
mantinha um amigo quanto era o diretor
de outra nossa hora de contar com o
futebolista hoje uma vez atrai sabiam
year lima da silva vinha pessoas elas
sabiam o que fazer afirma que serra
teria que ganhar no sábado ao remédio
estrada vicinal ninguém repetiu sua
bíblia que é o que ela vira regra
então vai parar de ganhar por exemplo
vocês da noite assim como é hora que
estava pra casa
uau você quiser ir embora e não viva
é verdade que você consegue conversar e
teria de dizer que esse momento marca
efetivamente na viagem de viragem à
direita mossul real
eles fazem parte dessa cidade pensa que
está a ser especialmente importante e
talvez após ele ter conseguido alma e
alegrar das quantidades de forma
completamente desidratada e mata bom por
marca não tentar direto com é que o tipo
de cultura quanto a criar um ateu de
cultura não é só a agricultura é só duas
filhas e executaram o o os bagos mais
preocupado não é só a implementação é só
acessar começou tudo isso tem que ter
atendimento enquanto e cultura o
ministro faça outra em busca de novas
que não é na estrada é a mesma cultura
de volta de toda aquela am em são paulo
fiquei impressionado com a cidade ficará
o quadro depois fazer a primeira pedida
há mais ou menos um ano depois disso foi
externo em 1943 mas menos um ano hoje
parece que vocês sempre ministério de
futebol com duas caixas de vinho era
previsível de souza elas que era o
resultado daquela nossa videla andrew e
oferece mais duas taças de vinho eram
duas garrafas do vinho e pela primeira
vez que tive dos guararapes pe pb e
romeu cria a tentação é chamar a mente e
mudar toda vejo apresentados aqui é
captado a consciência e egito como
oferecer todo o processo de confecção
pode mandar infinito entendimento com o
ministério
a ricoh do circo a sorte de ser seguido
pelo real continua a respeitar porque é
um minuto sequer possuir arma de pressão
para mim você é um produto respeitado
espalhar por um tempo pra mim muito
daquilo que eu era naquele dia
sempre está cada vez mais fraco tem mais
nada para especular cercá lo green day e
que observe violento e é um processo
onde milhares e eu imaginei dados sobre
fechar aquelas boas ferramentas que pode
ser que ele tenha uma garrafa de casa e
venceu neto de romper com os próximos
testes no brasil judicial abre uma
granada real deter esse fato para mim
cada um desejo real referiu que ainda
não sabe eu e minha pressa duas gatas
daquelas pra eu sei exatamente em que
comecei a consumir aquela daquelas duas
gráficas
isso quer dizer que essa que vocês
saibam respeitar aqui um minuto a minuto
consertar os supermercados e ir
diretamente para cercar os meninos sabem
o focus e tentar manter a linha eu quero
ter mais necessário seguir pessoal é
comprar um ou dois no peru foi muita
gente sob sol e uma gata e conheça o
recife também prendeu e 54 de pedra e
nadal tem opcionais no fim de que é um
canal assinala que você ou eu é
obrigatório você vive em inglês do
estado
depois também aconteceu uma coisa sempre
que viajar mesmo tempo próprio pensava
sempre qual era
a bancada mais próxima essa proposição
em terceiro pino as visitas e dizer uma
regra é eliminado do evento que
acontecia teriam estourado e diego bispo
dá por leonardo vídeo da série que fiz
lá existiam eu queria ou não surgirá a
volta do brasileiro subirá à volta dessa
cultura pessoal de fato há sempre uma
cultura mais trabalho para pensar nisso
é que 16 também é pesado
o projeto tinha em casa uma banda mas
agora minha vida da equipe espanhola o
espírito de perto as obras província
conselho mas só deu origem a volta de
felipe pradella e tudo isso no meu
telhado determina a vida das pessoas mas
o mais engraçado os seres mais engrossar
a partir daquela menina foi efetivamente
nos a entender ter um minuto que o ato
teria com o uaw o qual o que aumenta
para uma cultura começa a ouvir desde as
roupas no final de graça nova pintura
cultural da garrafa no bloco isso tudo
mais que isso
a cultura da mesa com gravata igual
muito como é que se passa nesse estado
para estado e conquistou hoje o momento
o animal é 19 quando quisesse c e nove
na memória não deixar que essa coisa de
dizer mal na costa filho foi não faça
uma farsa uma fácil como foi essa
transição da atenção para o facto
nada disso acontece sozinho teve el
mundo deve ser partilhado por ser algo
personalizado do sandero intermédio de
brasília e método histórico em alta os
mesmos estados o comigo os medicamentos
que sejam especiais distribuídos não sei
mas eu sempre te rouba um banco vista à
mesa e já tem que cuidar da beleza
o aumento do consumo com um mesmo em
como o produto e como o flu se eu parece
no fundo ele não vivia mais extrema que
hoje fico só você passar sem comprar
vinho design provável gestão daquela
fase cozinha própria pois mesmo na mesa
do que acompanhar a vida do tempo e
player como é que virá para que seja
prefeito valdomiro pessoa a toda essa
cultura feita com essa cultura acontece
acontece online acontece nas redes
sociais por descobrir com um fórum na
caloura e 71 528 escola era uma rede
social e que cometem algumas brasileiros
todos os dias de manhã uma sepsis 101
follow me down turistas todos e espalhar
por lá o que tenha um grito o tenha
comprado o livro estivesse a volta de
todos os dias falar ou se comunicavam
disco veio para criar preocupação
daquela plataforma digital foi assim
através de uma leitora que eu fiz a
minha primeira prova também fizeram os
22 pilotos aqui eu ia contar que a
moçada tem mais ela não apoiou o vídeo
possui naquela prova foi o francês por
ela
elogiamos prefeito frente
não vou dizer mas é mais protegida dos
vídeos compartilhados uma mesa com mais
pessoas e foi o objetivo é nos ao para
lá de ordem do constituinte socorro pode
ter um filho
o convite bom é a mesma conta a bonita e
com pessoas mais interessadas em
absorver de todas as componentes
essenciais de ouro numa época em que o
efeito foi feito assim quem está com o
resultado pois as inscrições neste tipo
de críticas que comem à mesa
fui incluído
fui humilhado e sobretudo perceber a
necessidade das redes sociais da escola
passou com 58
a nova política aqui os fogos possível
muitos críticos de lesões por são pedro
cenário verde irão cuidar dos filhos e
os netos daniel então eu fórum seu chefe
também cozinhas e astronomia
ou seja muita coisa boa do vídeo que na
melhoria e eu digo é só porque ganharam
tudo no início da noite ele quiser -
desenvolver termos de gráficos mas seria
melhor possível pois para ver se aquela
regulada início de 4.000 sei de fato é
imensamente no mundo feito dieta
distância por um homem trair já voltara
dias mesmo ou seja 15 dias e oferecerá
serviço s vídeo é muito simples é que
está constantemente a provar de que
estarmos a meta dizer sabiás para
crescer mais e mais e mais imagens
vídeos e mais as características do
vinho
a primeira coisa que faço é simples de
olhar para o qual eu vi no qual o olhar
pra eu ver pelas costas por vender o
vídeo pode ver se dá para fazer de mauro
dívida o conselheiro provas só tenho que
segurar na província em geral e minha
roupa
o rival que costuma usar toda a memória
que está para se perceber o que é o
vídeo sendo assim o gato sempre
recycling fazer com os parceiros do
goiano